bonsoir bienvenue meilleurs vœux à tous
un grand témoin ou plutôt un par un
exceptionnel ce soir pour nous
accompagner dans cette émission qui fait
peau neuve vous allez découvrir tout ça
bonsoir Thierry Marx et merci d'être la
chef étoilée bien sûr chef engagé sur
tout porte voir des restaurateurs en
crise aujourd'hui on va en parler on a
une heure en direct ensemble pour
commenter l'actualité de ce mardi 10
janvier l'actualité ce soir ce sont bien
sûr les retraites le gouvernement a
tranché il recule l'âge légal de départ
à 64 ans la bataille s'annonce rude dans
la rue la grève est déjà donnée pour le
19 janvier prochain à l'Assemblée y
a-t-il une voix de passage elle est
étroite retraite avec ou 149,3 c'est
notre grand débat dans un instant avec
nos invités puis à la fin de cette
émission de rendez-vous les cartes
blanches de nos affranchis aux alentours
de 20h15 pour leur parti pris et puis le
bourbon Express c'est une une nouvelle
rubrique chaque soir une histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée racontée par la
rédaction LCP voilà pour le menu Thierry
Marx vous êtes prêt je suis prêt sévère
nouvelle époque on y va
[Musique]
au boulot jusqu'à 64 ans ça y est c'est
officiel 64 ans c'est donc le nouvel âge
légal de départ proposé par le
gouvernement et Elisabeth borne vient de
présenter sa réforme c'était il y a
moins de deux heures le pari social il
est risqué ça on le sait ce qu'il est
gagnable ou pas on se pose la question
ce soir je vous présente mes invités
bonsoir Marc ferrachi et merci d'être là
depuis tes renaissance des Français
établis en Suisse ancien conseiller
social à Matignon et l'une des voix qui
nous dit on va peser dans ce débat dans
l'hémicycle bonsoir Stéphane Viry merci
d'être avec nous députés les
républicains des Vosges la droite qui
détient les clés de cette réforme vous
nous direz si le soutien DLR est acquis
ou pas au gouvernement ce soir bonsoir
Elsa faucillon bonsoir ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau député
communiste des Hauts de Seine membres de
la nuque la nuque radicalement opposée à
ce texte tout comme vous Sophie Binet
bonsoir secrétaire général de la CGT
cadre la CGD CGT réunis ce soir à la
Bourse du Travail en ce moment on en
parler l'ensemble des centrales
syndicales sont là-bas pour dessiner
d'une mobilisation contre cette réforme
Thierry Marx elle concerne tout le monde
cette réforme un les citoyens que nous
sommes et aussi les restaurateurs que
vous représentez donc vous êtes
évidemment invité à intervenir quand
vous le souhaitez mais on commence comme
chaque soir avec la ni blackkowski qui
s'est donné un défi de taille pour cette
nouvelle année nous planter le décor et
sur les retraites c'est pas évident en
200 secondes ça s'appelle le chrono de
Blacko et on l'accueille tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et à tous j'espère que vous
êtes en pleine forme du haut de cette
extrade
l'essentiel des annonces d'Elisabeth
borne en 200 secondes c'est à vous alors
je vous dis tout de suite je suis un peu
perplexe Myriam vous me demandez de
l'expliquer en 200 secondes les réformes
de retraites prévues par Elisabeth donc
moi avec ce grand écran tout neuf à côté
de nous je me dis bah on va mettre une
photo d'Elizabeth borne sauf que je me
demande si cette photo est vraiment bien
choisie pour illustrer la chronique
parce qu'en fait la photo qu'il faudrait
mettre celui qui mériterait de donner
son nom à cette réforme des retraites
c'est qui bah c'est plutôt lui alors ça
vous surprend ce devoir apparaître Erik
sotti en attendant la réforme qui a été
présentée ce soir par Elizabeth band
c'est exactement celle que réclamait ce
dimanche Eric Ciotti bah justement dans
le Journal du dimanche il avait employé
une formule il faut atténuer la
brutalité de cette réforme on dirait du
Laurent verger et bien pas du tout c'est
du Eric chiotière le premier point sur
lequel insistait eriki dans le JDD
c'était le recul de
[Musique]
à partir seulement de 2035 on avait le
temps et là il y a eu un gros coup
d'accélération
ericsiotti avait demandé une
accélération mais c'était encore plus
fort que ça parce qu'elle sera dès 2027
qu'on aura besoin de ces 43 à l'unité et
puis il y avait vraiment un troisième
point sur lequel un système
Eric Ciotti c'était la question de la
revalorisation des pensions des petites
pensions à 1200 euros mais attention pas
seulement pour ceux qui vont bientôt
être à la retraite aussi pour ceux qui
sont déjà à la retraite est-ce qu'elles
avaient une borne a tenu compte de ce
que tu viens exotique on se demande le
système c'est insoutenable on écoute
certains groupes parlementaires je pense
aux républicains ont insisté sur la
nécessité de prendre en compte les
retraités actuels avec le président de
la République nous avons décidé
d'intégrer dans notre projet la
revalorisation des pensions de retraite
actuelle pour tous ceux qui ont une
carrière complète au niveau du SMIC donc
vu que vous n'avez donné que 200
secondes je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails il faut peut-être juste insister
sur ce qui a été prévu pour les
carrières longues Elizabeth borne a pas
mal insisté là-dessus je vous montre le
petit travelo encore il y a cette idée
d'être progressivement selon au cas par
cas pour faire des cas par cas donc ceux
qui ont commencé avant 14 ans ils sont
rares mais ils pourront partir à 58 ans
puis voyez progressivement 6061 ceux qui
ont commencé entre 18 et 20 ans pourront
partir à 62 ans je sens qu'il est temps
de conclure j'ai pas exactement le
chrono en tête je voudrais juste faire
peur de mon étonnement c'est à dire que
là il y a quand même un accord entre
Élisabeth borne ancienne conseillère de
Lionel Jospin qu'on disait l'aile gauche
avec
Eric Ciotti qui lors de la essentiel se
disait prêt à voter plutôt pour Zemmour
que pour Macron donc on se demande
lequel des deux a le plus viré de bord
bon en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
s'ils sont ensemble à l'Assemblée en
revanche dans la rue c'est les syndicats
qui vont être réunis le débat peut
commencer je vous préviens même si vous
n'avez pas le temps de tout dire il y
aura d'autres débats
merci merci beaucoup Stéphane c'était
très clair Paris relevé et c'est
toujours aussi piquant on va commencer
par les 64 ans le recul de l'âge légal
marquerait la mesure la plus impopulaire
je suis sûr que vous avez vu ce sondage
80% des Français sont hostiles au recul
de l'âge il y avait vraiment aucune
autre option c'est pas une surprise que
ce soit une mesure non il y a pas une
seule réforme des retraites quel qu'il
s'agisse du recul de l'âge légal ou de
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
d'ailleurs qui dans la dernière année a
été populaire pourquoi c'est important
toucher l'âge légal parce que c'est le
levier le plus efficace tout le démontre
y compris l'histoire d'ailleurs pour
augmenter le taux d'emploi des gens qui
sont dans cette classe d'âge et on sait
que le taux d'emploi des seniors et bien
il est plus faible en France même
beaucoup plus faible en France pour les
60 64 ans que dans les autres pays
pour justifier 64 ans vous ne me parlez
pas d'équilibre financier je m'étonne
j'arrive là c'est précisément parce que
c'est le levier le plus efficace pour
augmenter le taux d'emploi que ça le
plus gros impact financier et c'est très
important cette idée d'impact financier
parce que derrière cette réforme et
l'idée de préserver notre modèle par
répartition vraiment il est il est
menacé
il en va dans un modèle en péril
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'est un modèle qui est déjà en déficit
parce que l'État contribue avec son
budget à l'équilibre d'un certain nombre
de régimes les régimes de la fonction
publique les régimes spéciaux comme
celui de la SNCF à hauteur de 30
milliards d'euros dès aujourd'hui avant
même que les évolutions démographiques
ne se manifestent et les évolutions
démographiques on les connaît bien il y
avait trois cotisants pour un actif en
1970 il y en avait deux pour un actif en
2000 il y en
il y en aura 1,4 en 2050 ça veut dire
très concrètement que à l'instar de ce
qui s'est passé dans les autres pays on
doit tenir compte de cette évolution
démographique moi je veux insister et je
vais essayer de la parole à mes
collègues ensuite sur la préservation de
ce modèle si on laisse dériver les
déficits et on sait que le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites le dit bien
si
à l'horizon 2027 et ensuite ça monte
jusqu'à 25 milliards donc ça c'est ça
c'est très
importants de recettes liées au
cotisations retraite une grosse dizaine
de milliards c'est peu oui mais je ne
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec lui
parce que le principe d'un système par
répartition c'est d'être équilibré les
cotisations des actifs des gens qui
travaillent doivent payer les pensions
des gens qui ne travaillent plus à
partir du moment on accepte des déficits
qui vont s'accumuler et qu'on va laisser
en dette à notre enfant on change la
nature de notre système on n'est plus
dans un système par répartition alors on
peut dire le système tiendra toujours
oui le système sera toujours si on
augmente les impôts si on augmente la
dette qu'on laissera nos enfants et de
cela nous ne voulons pas c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous faisons cette réforme
alors Stéphane Viry c'est la réforme
borne ou c'est la réforme fioti comme le
disait Stéphane lakowski ce que vous
réclamiez a été retenu ou quasiment
alors écoutez ce n'est pas la réforme
Macron version octobre 2022 qui nous
apparaissait brutal et totalement une
acceptable compte tenu de la situation
sociale et du pays c'était donc non pour
nous sauf si il y avait effectivement
une atténuation et une approche de cette
question de la réforme des retraites qui
pour nous est essentielle nous ne sommes
pas de ceux qui considèrent
qu'effectivement le sujet n'est pas à
évoquer il y a effectivement à terme à
péril pour le pour la retraite par
répartition et il faut traiter le sujet
avec courage néanmoins effectivement
à 1200 avec
possibilités
on ne va pas vous donner notre plaisir
donc vous voterez non on en est pas là
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'accord à ce
stade
il y a a débat parlementaire qui va
commencer et sur les déclarations de
Madame borne ce soir il y a encore un
certain d'incertitudes il y a encore une
marge de manœuvre pour que la réforme
soit acceptable on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui d'avoir réussi à aboutir à
une réforme qui est plus juste que ce
que voulait manuel Macron notamment sur
les pensions les plus faibles à 1200
euros y compris pour les retraites
actuels mais vous avez encore des
conditions lesquelles il y a
effectivement alors déjà sur le fait que
les pensionnés actuels
bénéficieront de la de la pension à 1200
euros ça reste encore un certain j'ai
entendu la première ministre qui aurait
un effort elle m'a elle a pas dit que
c'était acté sur la question de tenir
compte de la durée des cotisations 43
pour pouvoir partir avant l'âge légal je
n'ai pas eu la certitude que c'était
acté et pour nous ce sont des lignes
rouges donc il reste à mon avis encore
des points à travailler et moi je suis
parlementaire et je vais effectivement
qu'il y a débat qui m'apparaissent
constructive dans le cas de la musique
avocat ce stade la position de vote des
réplica elle est totalement non figée le
diable extrêmement politique on l'a bien
compris elles a foncées faucillon 64 ans
d'abord ça ça reste en dessous de l'âge
légal dans dans les autres pays
européens la plupart 65 en Allemagne 66
en Espagne 67 en Italie
c'est une telle ligne rouge pour vous
oui c'est une ligne rouge et puis vous
savez pendant des années il y a de
nombreux pays dans le monde qui nous ont
en vie notre système de sécurité sociale
de protection sociale de santé publique
et les politiques de gestion des Léo
libérale les ont largement abîmé et
force est de constater que ces actes qui
ont produit le fait et bien qu'on nous
regarde avec moins d'envie sur sur notre
sur notre système donc quand on est en
capacité
d'apporter du progrès de l'amélioration
dans la vie des gens on le fait et moi
je pense que c'est possible aujourd'hui
et possible c'est possible pour les
retraits avec les références
que je comprends que le gouvernement
choisisse de raccourcir un maximum les
débats il pense que comme ça ces
arguments pourront tenir sur une petite
durée mais même la durée qui va nous
être offerte on va s'en saisir et je
peux vous dire et pédagogie je peux vous
dire je peux vous dire que la méthode
vont très vite tomber là où dénoncer la
méthode parlementaire peut-être un mot
d'explication pour ceux qui nous
regardent c'est un budget socialiste
exactement et donc d'abord c'est inédit
qu'on transforme à ce point le système
de retraite dans le cadre d'un projet de
loi de finance rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale ça implique un temps
très très court donc à partir du moment
où le gouvernement va être des
nationales sauf qu'on n'aura pas 20
jours de débat d'accord parce qu'il
s'arrange pour que le temps soit un
maximum raccourci que si on n'arrive pas
au bout des 50 jours prévus pour
l'Assemblée et le Sénat et bien le
gouvernement peut fonctionner par
ordonnance ça s'appelle un passage en
force c'est un 49-3 qui dit pas son nom
et il y a un gouvernement là d'ailleurs
qui fait comme si le Parlement n'allait
pas passer sur ce qu'il vient ce qu'il
vient d'annoncer on véritablement un
passage en force alors que vous l'avez
rappelé 80% de des citoyens de ce pays
sont opposés à ces 64 ans qu'il y a un
front syndical uni très opposé aussi à
ses 75 à venir dans un instant et donc
nous on va dans le débat dans une
opposition résolue mais aussi avec des
propositions démonter cet argument qui
tant à prouver que le système par
répartition serait en péril et que la
seule solution serait de faire partir
les gens plus tard c'est un débat droit
de gauche extrêmement promet
et franchement ça va tomber très vite et
moi ce que je vois c'est qu'il y a un
gouvernement qui a refusé d'entendre les
propositions qui permettaient que des
recettes supplémentaires existent qui a
baissé les impôts de production des
entreprises et qui entend le faire et
qui ne veut pas dire aux citoyens de ce
pays que c'est pour cette raison qui
veulent les faire travailler plus tard
pour moi les arguments qui sont
développés aujourd'hui par par le
gouvernement et par la majorité sont des
arguments malhonnêtes vis-à-vis des
Français
va essayer de rentrer dans le détail je
termine le tour de table parce qu'il y a
quand même des dispositifs de d'éléments
de justice notamment sur des carrières
longues et la pénibilité Sophie Binet la
CGT c'est nous en bloc l'objectif c'est
quoi dans la rue aujourd'hui c'est
d'obtenir l'abandon de ce texte là oui
et puis surtout d'obtenir un autre texte
parce qu'en fait nous on satisfait pas
du statu quo on a des propositions de
vous reconnaissez qu'il faut le réformer
ce modèle de retraite aujourd'hui oui
parce que malheureusement on a subi 8
réformes successives depuis 1993 qui à
chaque fois c'était la même chose le
même scénario sur le système étant
déficit c'est une catastrophe il faut
réformer et à chaque fois on demande aux
salariés de passer à la caisse et on
exonère le revenir au 60 ans là CGT veut
revenir au 60 ans avec 75% du dernier
salaire parce qu'en fait si on lit le
rapport du corps le problème c'est pas
le fait que le régime va s'effondrer
d'ailleurs le corps l'écrit le problème
c'est que par contre c'est le niveau des
pensions qui vont s'effondrer du fait
d'être successives et là-dessus le
rapport du corps est utilisé si je peux
me permettre par toutes les dans ce
dossier sensible
2021-2022 il est excédentaire mais à
partir de 2027 le déficit se creuse 12
milliards puis 14 milliards en 2021 et
encore plus tard nous ce qu'on souhaite
c'est parler financement on a des
propositions de financement très
précises les 15 milliards qui sont
brandis comme la catastrophe pour le
régime on peut les trouver très
facilement il suffirait d'augmenter d'un
point les cotisations pour dégager 15
milliards et ça serait c'est pas la
meilleure solution qu'on préconise
par ailleurs il y a plein d'autres
leviers je rappelle que cette année les
dividendes et les sommes versées aux
actionnaires atteignent un record on est
à 80 milliards donc mettre à
contribution les revenus financiers des
entreprises ça ferait rentrer de
l'argent je rappelle également que les
exonérations fiscales et sociales chaque
année atteignent 159 milliards d'euros
chaque année qui ne sont pas
conditionnés pas évalués on même pas
capable de dire le nombre de niches
fiscales et sociales peut-être que la
priorité ça serait de faire ça de
toucher à ça et trouver comme ça des
moyens de financer notre système social
de l'argent c'est ce que dit la CGT que
la gauche a du PS et ou même madame
Binet vous voulez mettre fin au système
par répartition vous voulez mettre fin
système par les partition pourquoi parce
qu'un système qui est financé par de la
fiscalité qui est financé par ce qu'on
va chercher dans le budget de l'État
avec toutes les mesures que vous
proposez mais je suis désolé ça n'est
plus un système par
répartitions de cotisations c'est vous
qui augmentez de façon constante la CSG
parler le principe d'un système par
répartition c'est la solidarité entre
les générations les actifs payent pour
les retraités vous vous nous dites que
tout un tas d'autres agents et acteurs
économiques peuvent payer les
entreprises les dividendes les
actionnaires c'est que ça remettrait en
question la notion même de solidarité
intergénérationnelle ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point que je veux
partager
c'est votre projet de société et je vais
aller sur ce deuxième point qui est
l'augmentation des cotisations
un tout petit peu les cotisations
retraite ça pourrait financer le système
dans cette majorité nous avons depuis
2017 une logique qui est de ne pas
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
et plutôt de les baisser parce que nous
considérons que ces créateurs d'emploi
en particulier du côté des entreprises
il y a un organisme qui s'appelle l'OFCE
vous connaissez sans doute qu'on ne
classe d'ailleurs pas de plus pas trop à
droite mais plutôt à gauche qui a mené
une analyse qu'on retrouve dans la note
d'un autre organisme qui s'appelle
Terranova et qu'on classe aussi plutôt à
gauche
qui nous dit peut-être mais en tout cas
le site mes sources ou là de mettre qui
nous dit quoi qui nous dit que augmenter
d'un point parce que c'est à peu près ce
qui serait nécessaire dans les analyses
le taux de cotisation sur la basse
salariale globale des entreprises en
réalité ça n'apporterait pas un point de
cotisation à notre système de retraite
pourquoi parce que ça détruerait de
l'emploi ça dégraderait la compétitivité
des entreprises c'est ce qui écrit le FC
voilà et ça ne génère que 0,2 points de
cotisation en plus donc il faut avoir
conscience de ça il faut pas penser
qu'augmenter les impôts qu'augmenter les
prélèvements obligatoires c'est toujours
la réponse à tout nous avons choisi
quelque chose qui vous l'avez rappelé a
été la démarche choisie par à peu près
tous nos voisins ça veut pas dire je
vous rejoins il faut pas que on fasse
toujours comme les autres mais il faut
de temps en temps qu'on regarde ce que
font les autres ne pas penser qu'on a
toujours raison en France on a choisi on
a choisi effectivement d'allonger la
durée de travail et de l'allonger on la
compensant par un certain nombre de
mesures j'espère qu'on va en parler et
qui font de cet enfant je pense une
équilibrée
j'en termine avec ça les 1200 euros de
retraite minimum et n'en déplaise à mon
collègue Stéphane Viry l'idée de les
appliquer à la totalité des retraités
était une idée défendue par le Président
de la République durant sa campagne mais
on va pas cette mesure on va pas si
c'est pour tous les retraités actuels ça
coûte combien ça
correspond à un million 800 mille
personnes qui concrètement ont une
carrière complète parce que j'insiste
c'est une mesure qui vaudra pour les
gens qui ont tout leur trimestres pour
les gens qui n'ont pas tout leur
trimestres j'ajoute parce que je sais
que c'est un argument qui revient on
préserve le principe de la possibilité
de partir en retraite à 67 ans sans
décote ce qui est si vous êtes trop oui
mais ce que je veux dire oui mais sauf
que lorsque vous augmentez la logique
c'est que lorsque vous augmentez la
génial vous décalez
ce principe qui justement est favorable
aux gens qui ont eu des carrières
hachées et se sont principalement des
femmes et préservées
on va rentrer dans le détail et on va
vous montrer un reportage sur la
pénibilité parce que la question c'est
est-ce qu'elle est juste cette réforme
Thierry Marx c'est un débat extrêmement
clivé comme moi le citoyen que vous êtes
on vous dit d'un côté le système est en
péril de l'autre côté non on pouvait ne
pas y toucher
de regarder le fonctionnement de la
société le nouveau fonctionnement de la
société on voit bien que un problème
démographique ça c'est une évidence et
que les entreprises va supporter non
plus trop de poids sur leur cotisation
mais en même temps on touche un symbole
fort
quel symbole des retraites qui est un
acquis social et effectivement ça va
forcément faire un débat très tendu
comment on préserve moi je pense
toujours à ceux qui ont de la pénibilité
au travail comment ils accompagnent très
tôt pour arriver jusqu'à l'âge de la
retraite en gardant aussi le bénéfice on
oublie le bénéfice de nos aînés dans les
entreprises et ça il faut le aussi le
défendre c'est ça que je suis très
partagé sur le débat parce
qu'effectivement moi dans nos
entreprises on aime bien garder nos
anciens et les accompagner justement
pour qu'ils deviennent jusqu'à l'âge de
la retraite dans les meilleures
conditions possibles alors ça sera
l'objet d'un autre débat on est obligé
un peu de chapitrer des choses il y a
tellement qui viennent notamment la
question d'un index dans les entreprises
sur l'emploi des seigneurs je vais voilà
dire noter les spectateurs un élément de
coulisses on est obligé de vous vous
laissez repartir parce que dans
l'hémicycle vous pouvez peut-être nous
expliquer marque Ferracci qui est en
train de se jouer ce studio il est dans
le Palais Bourbon et donc vous allez
voter c'est ça
sur un ce qu'on appelle un vote
solennelle avec à peu près tous les
missiles remplis et on a eu un problème
technique de vote électronique donc on
n'a pas pu voter et donc c'est
fondamental sur les énergies
renouvelables auxquelles on tient
évidemment beaucoup et donc en fait on
nous attend pour voter à l'urne c'est ça
la nouvelle donne politique à
l'Assemblée
et donc on va devoir malheureusement
quitter le plateau
en tout cas
on termine ce tour de table des
positions politiques donnée aussi la
parole aux rassemblement national Marco
pommier vous êtes avec Laure La Valette
aux quatre colonnes c'est une ligne
rouge aussi pour le rassemblement
national que que c'est 64 ans d'âge
légal oui Myriam leur La Valette c'est
désormais un officiel il faudrait il
faudra travailler plus longtemps jusqu'à
64 ans à l'horizon 2030 c'était une
ligne rouge pour vous ah oui depuis le
début vous savez les Français ont voté
pour nous justement parce qu'il savait
que nous allions nous opposer à cette
réforme des retraites après voilà un peu
d'étonnement parce qu'on attendait une
réforme systémique on attendait voilà
que du seul au plafond touchant et on se
retrouve avec une réforme finalement
assez paramétrique avec simplement cet
âge de légal de départ à la retraite qui
se rallonge qui est exactement l'inverse
de ce que disait Emmanuel Macron en 2019
souvenez-vous quand il disait ce serait
complètement hypocrite de rallonger
simplement l'âge puisque ce que
budgétairement on pense pouvoir gagner
on va le dépenser en mesure sociale et
en mesure au niveau de chômage puisqu'on
sait quand même 40 % des seniors qui
arrivent à l'âge de la retraite soit
sont soit en maladie soit sans emploi
juste trop justement à propos de social
est-ce que vous avez quand même des
points de convergence avec le
gouvernement est-ce que par exemple vous
voterez cette pension minimale à 1200
euros pour les retraités alors déjà il
va falloir qu'on en parle savoir
exactement qui est-ce que ça va
concerner parce que 1200 euros d'appeler
leurs calculs ça me paraît un peu
étrange ça voudrait dire qu'il
n'augmente que de 100 euros pour arriver
à 1200 euros donc on va déjà commencer à
refaire ces calculs il faut voir qui ça
concerne exactement je rappelle que je
pense que ce sont les carrières
complètement pleines donc il faut voir
le nombre de gens que ça que ça concerne
après par exemple le cumul emploi
retraite nous paraît être une bonne idée
évidemment si les retraités peuvent
améliorer leur pouvoir d'achat voilà
nous aurons le même bon sens que nous
avons depuis le début et si un
amendement va dans le bon sens de votre
rond mais l'esprit globale de cette loi
vous avez nous ne pensons qu'elle est
injuste parce que c'est la France qui se
lève tôt qui va payer pour les mauvais
choix politiques qui ont appauvri la
France et on pense surtout qu'elle est
inutile parce qu'effectivement ce
déficit qui a annoncé par le corps déjà
est-ce qu'il arrivera vraiment je vous
rappelle que le corps prédisait que là
on se rend déficit qui n'est pas le cas
puisque nous sommes accidentaires et ce
déficit même s'il est par exemple de 10
milliards d'euros est un déficit que
nous aurions assumé encore une fois il y
a un choix de société qui est derrière
tout ça et c'est un peu dis-moi quelle
est la réforme de retraite que tu veux
et je te dirai la société dans laquelle
je veux faire vivre les gens et nous
nous voulions que les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt vous savez
entre 17 et 20 ans puissent partir à la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités
pleines et qu'après il y ait une
progressivité qu'à 62 ans ce soit l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite ce qui
n'empêche pas les gens de continuer à
travailler s'ils en ont envie alors dans
la bataille parlementaire qui s'annonce
qu'elle va être la stratégie du
rassemblement national est-ce que vous
comptez par exemple faire obstruction en
déposant
des milliers d'amendements non enfin
vous êtes observateur de la vie
politique vous savez bien que ça dépend
notre façon de faire depuis le début
nous sommes constructifs nous respectons
les institutions dans lesquelles nous
sommes nous respectons évidemment
l'émission nous respectons le mandat que
les Français nous ont donné et nous
allons user de tous les moyens j'allais
dire normaux du bon fonctionnement des
institutions donc on va prendre la
parole amender on va parlementer et on
va essayer de faire un fléchir le
gouvernement mais pas d'obstruction on
laisse ça vous savez à la nupes nous
nous sommes en partie de gouvernement
nous nous préparons évidemment à
gouverner le pays et à être l'alternance
à Emmanuel Macron merci beaucoup Laurent
La Valette merci à vous merci à vous
Marco pommier un débat dans l'hémicycle
qui s'annonce musclé vous l'aurez
compris il commencera à la fin du mois
en commission des affaires sociales et
puis un bras de fer dans la rue
également Sophie Binet on va en parler
de ce climat social et syndicats qui
sont réunis ce soir à la Bourse du
Travail bonsoir Clément Perrot et merci
d'être avec nous Clément les centrales
qui doivent décider des modalités de la
mobilisation ou en étant ce soir
19 janvier Myriam jeudi 19 janvier voilà
la date compte arrêté les organisations
syndicales réunies ce soir à la Bourse
du travail à Paris au programme de cette
journée du 19 janvier et bien une
mobilisation générale avec à la fois des
grèves des débrayages et bien sûr des
manifestations sur tout le territoire
ont prévenu les différents secrétaires
généraux des organisations syndicales je
vous propose d'écouter Laurent Berger
les organisations syndicales sont toutes
unanimes pour dire que le report de Las
Vegas une mesure brutale qui va d'abord
concerner les travailleurs et les plus
modestes il n'y a pas de répartition des
efforts c'est sur les seuls travailleurs
que repose cette réforme par un
allongement de la durée de travail donc
voilà on a décidé de réagir ensemble
pour contrer cette réforme qui est
injuste pour les travailleurs et les
travailleuses je les appelle avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
à se mobiliser
voilà et je suis avec Cyril Chabanier
président de la CFTC bonsoir Monsieur
chavanier cette date du 19 janvier elle
va intervenir vite l'idée c'était de
frapper vite et fort oui c'était de
frapper vite effort ça fait un petit
moment qu'on avait dit l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales que s'il y
avait un décalage en report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite nous
ferions une grande manifestation et nous
serions tous ensemble aujourd'hui nous
nous sommes réunis il y a eu l'annonce
de ce report on voulait taper vite et
fort le 19 janvier on sera les premiers
à lancer et c'était important que les
organisations syndicales lancent en
premier cette grande manifestation sur
tout le territoire parce qu'on sait que
le gouvernement aujourd'hui est
déterminé et la seule chance de pouvoir
faire reculer ce gouvernement c'est
d'être le plus nombreux possible dans la
rue et c'est pour ça que nous sommes
tous unis c'est déjà la logique du
rapport de force on est dans la logique
du rapport de force puisque sur le
financement on n'a pas pu faire entendre
nos propositions on n'a pas pu discuter
depuis le départ on nous ça sera le
report de l'âge légal et aucune autre
proposition ont été étudiées et pourtant
d'un ami plusieurs dizaines sur la table
et donc évidemment aujourd'hui vu que le
débat parlementaire va être en plus
réduit et restreint il faut qu'on aille
très vite il faut qu'on frappe très fort
dès le 19 janvier ça nous laisse quand
même une semaine pour s'organiser il
faut absolument que des millions de
personnes soient dans la rue avec nous
pour faire reculer ce gouvernement merci
Monsieur Chabanier voilà Myriam je vous
rappelle l'information principale donc
19 janvier ce sera la première grande
journée de mobilisation des syndicats
merci beaucoup Clément perbot Sophie
Binet bon voilà déjà une date commune de
mobilisation comment vous allez opérer
c'est un mouvement déjà reconductible
pourquoi ne pas appeler on sent que vous
êtes vraiment très hostile à cette
réforme à la grève générale directement
non mais c'est comme d'habitude c'est à
dire que là il y a une première journée
de mobilisation qui le le caractère
exceptionnel c'est d'abord qu'il y a
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
qu'il appelle ça faisait 12 ans que ça
avait pas été le cas qu'en plus c'est
très rapide et ça montre bien la forte
colère et la détestation syndicales et
ensuite on se reverra le 19 au soir pour
décider des suites et surtout ce qui se
passe c'est ça va se construire sur le
terrain en fait et donc là il y a des
inter syndicales qui vont s'organiser
dans tous les territoires dans toutes
les entreprises dans toutes les branches
professionnelles et qui vont décliner
cet appel et qui vont prendre des
décisions pour ce qui les concerne donc
il y a des endroits en fonction du
rapport de force peut-être que la grève
reconductible va se construire à partir
du 19 janvier après c'est les salariés
qu'ils décident en fait nous les
constructions de la mobilisation elles
se font démocratiquement avec les
salariés et là le message que nous
passons c'est il faut être le plus
nombreux possible le 19 janvier pour
faire reculer le gouvernement un peu
plus vite possible pour parler de
construire démocratiquement c'est votre
terme cette mobilisation contre la
réforme la démocratie elle va être aussi
ici au Parlement à l'Assemblée nationale
si d'ici la fin du mois de février
puisqu'on va y avoir un texte dans
l'hémicycle début février ce texte est
adopté est-ce que la CGT respectera la
représentation nationale non mais le la
CGT elle est opposée à ce texte elle se
battra jusqu'au bout contre le report de
l'âge de départ en retraite parce qu'on
trouve que c'est une mesure qui est
brutale violente et injuste et qui n'est
pas justifié par la situation économique
du régime et qui aurait d'autres
possibilités qu'on a fait entendre c'est
une réforme qui est extrêmement brutale
parce qu'elle va commencer à s'appliquer
dès la génération 1961 ça veut dire des
personnes qui allaient partir en
retraite là on leur dit qu'ils doivent
travailler plus longtemps c'est une
réforme particulièrement injuste et elle
va notamment augmenter les inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes et il y
avait plein d'autres façons de faire
autrement c'est ça qui rageant donc nous
on accepte pas on acceptera pas cette
réforme qui est totalement scandaleuse
et qui va faire baisser l'espérance de
vie parce que la santé elle tient aussi
du fait qu'on peut avoir une retraite
pour pas multiplier les incapacités qui
va faire
errance de vie augmente l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé reste ici en retraite
l'espérance de vie elle va baisser et
puis ça va faire exploser le le chômage
des seniors et ça va faire chuter les
pensions parce qu'on va être plus
nombreuses et nombreux à partir avec des
carrières incomplètes et donc avec des
petites retraites notamment pour les
femmes Thierry Marx avant de parler de
vos nombreuses casquettes un mot sur la
pénibilité les restaurateurs en savent
quelque chose
il va y avoir des critères carrière
longue faire en sorte que si on revienne
peut-être à des critères de pénibilité
les charges lourdes notamment le travail
de nuit ça c'est indispensable et le
travail debout longtemps dans des zones
de chaleur enfin et oui il y a tout État
regardé sur la pénibilité au travail
parce que là il faut un véritable
accompagnement pour ces retraites con
que l'âge de la retraite évolue la
société évolue on peut regarder ça dans
le détail mais effectivement la
pénibilité au travail c'est un sujet
permanent dans les entreprises et
d'accompagner au mieux nos salariés vers
une retraite
là-dessus tout de même quand on regarde
les les éléments d'annonce sur les
carrières longues finalement avant 20
ans on part
60 62 maximum donc ça il y a une prise
en compte non en fait aujourd'hui les
carrières longues on peut partir à 60
ans demain avec la réforme on partira à
62 ans donc c'est un recul pour
l'écrasante majorité des salariés en
carrière longue et alors sur la
pénibilité j'en parle même pas
aujourd'hui le compte individuel de
prévention n'a pas eu comment gain de
cause notamment sur le suivi médical le
suivi médical c'est un suivi individuel
ça va rien changer en fait la question
c'est qui va pouvoir partir plutôt parce
que la pénibilité c'est un sujet majeur
je rappelle que ça concerne 40% des
salariés qui ont au moins un critère de
pénibilité 10% qui en ont trois et le
problème c'est que le compte individuel
de pénibilité aujourd'hui c'est moins de
2% des salariés qui peuvent partir plus
tôt parce qu'il y a des critères qui
sont pas pris en compte et ça le
gouvernement nous dit rien là-dessus
parce que les seuils d'exposition ont
trop élevés et parce qu'en plus le
compte fonctionne de façon individuelle
et pas collective et ça il fallait le
réviser on avait fait des propositions
que le gouvernement a refusé d'examiner
donc en matière dans les arguments
la bataille elle est elle est lancée
c'est évident on va la suivre jour après
jour semaine après semaine merci Sophie
Vinet d'être venu commenter à chaud les
annonces sur cette réforme des retraites
Thierry Marx vous restez donc avec moi
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
pris de nos affranchis ils vont vous
faire réagir vous allez le voir ce soir
le coup de gueule de la chamboncelle sur
le plancha du gouvernement le regard de
Richard Verly sur les résistances de nos
démocraties malgré le putsch de Brasilia
et puis Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'assemblée qui nous dit pourquoi
ça traîne autant ce vote sur les
énergies renouvelables dans dans
l'hémicycle à tout de suite les amis on
parle un petit peu de vous à présent
Thierry Marx tout de suite avec ce
portrait signer Marco polonais
si on vous invite Thierry Marx c'est
parce que le chef étoilé que vous êtes
c'est piqué de politique on vous
découvre aujourd'hui à la tête du
premier syndicat patronal de
l'hôtellerie restauration président de
l'uni on vous appelle Monsieur le Chef
président maintenant
et je resterai un artisan un artisan
mais aussi un combattant ceinture noire
de karaté boxeur des coups vous en avez
pris dans la vie vous auriez pu mal
tourner
né dans le pari populaire des années 70
à Ménilmontant vous avez une adolescence
tourmentée vous le dur à cuire en
rupture avec le système scolaire on nous
a exclu d'un système parce qu'on n'était
pas compris parce qu'on rentrait pas
dans le format on rentrait pas dans le
cadre Thierry Marx vous êtes atypique
une vie singulière casque bleu pendant
la guerre au Liban convoyeur de fonds
vigile et aujourd'hui chef cuisinier
c'est devant les fourneaux que s'exprime
votre passion canette à Saint-Pierre un
bœuf charbon deux étoiles au guide
Michelin pionniers de la cuisine
moléculaire quand la gastronomie se
marie avec la science pour le grand
public vous êtes ce jurer impitoyable
dans Top Chef une image qui en cache une
autre celle d'un chef cuistot engagé à
la fibre sociale avec vos écoles de
cuisine gratuite sans oublier vos cours
personnalisés pour les prisonniers
se reconstruise il faut montrer un
centre de direction moi je crois que le
travail est épanouissant aujourd'hui
syndicaliste porte-voix des
restaurateurs un nouveau combat pour
défendre un secteur éprouvé crise
sanitaire pénurie de main d'oeuvre
inflation sur les matières premières et
l'énergie alors vous mettez les pieds
dans le plat et vous aussi le ton contre
le gouvernement et qu'il mette la
pression sur les fournisseurs d'énergie
c'est pas faut mettre la pression alors
Thierry Marx ce soir on a une question
pour vous entre la toque de cuisinier et
la casquette de syndicaliste laquelle
préférez-vous
[Musique]
c'est vrai ça c'est quand même très
différent cette nouvelle casquette
Thierry Marx qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé
d'ailleurs à accepter de prendre les
reines de l'humide dans un contexte très
difficile l'attractivité métier et puis
de faire évoluer nos professions parce
que elle lui on encadre ensemble de
profession lié à l'hôtellerie la
restauration les débits de boissons et
bien d'autres choses donc à un moment
donné je pense qu'on peut pas rester à
l'extérieur et il faut venir un petit
peu comme ça essayer de faire évoluer
vous aimez ça négocier d'ailleurs dans
les ministères comme vous l'avez fait
encore tout récemment non non j'aime le
côté associatif de ma vie parce que je
trouve que dans l'associatif on met de
côté un peu les idéologies et efficace
c'est pour ça qu'elle lui j'ai essayé de
construire comme une association de gens
bienveillants qui disent effectivement
on est à une époque où il faut faire
évoluer notre métier dans sa
communication dans son impact social et
dans son impact environnemental alors on
va parler des restaurateurs que vous
représentez l'hôtellerie la Restauration
il y a évidemment l'inflation les prix
des denrées alimentaires qui qui
augmentent le beurre la farine et puis
bien sûr les factures énergétiques qui
explosent parfois elles font x 10 dans
certains établissements est-ce que vous
diriez que c'est plus dur encore pour
les restaurants que pendant le covid
oui c'est plus dur parce que on a des
phénomènes cumulés c'est-à-dire que le
la situation sanitaire on la connaissait
on a été démonétisés pendant cette
situation sanitaire donc évidemment il a
fallu s'endetter on a pris ses pré
garanties par l'État on réouvre on fait
plutôt une bonne saison et arrive
effectivement cette inflation des coûts
des matières premières et ensuite mais
là c'est plus une inflation c'est
vraiment presque un raquette au niveau
du de l'énergie et là effectivement il y
a beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
sont qui sont à la limite à la limite
certains dépôts de bilan bien sûr c'est
clair d'ailleurs on a nos confrères en
Périgord qui a fermé son établissement
qui est un établissement parfaitement
étoilé énormément des boulangers en ce
moment vous diriez que la crise traverse
le cauchemar les boulangers c'est des
petits artisans on est à moins de 10
salariés est-ce qu'on peut comparer la
crise que traverse les restaurants
boulangers ou c'est pas comparable moi
j'aime pas comparer comparaison des
poisons pour moi mais il faut défendre
boulanger bien sûr et c'est TPE de la
boulangerie mais nous on parle de
restaurant les boulangers n'ont pas été
fermés nous avons été fermés nous avons
été démonétisés par exemple d'autres
donc on s'est endetté donc on sort
finalement de cette crise sanitaire vous
voulez dire que vous avez été il y a eu
du chômage partiels
favorables mais on a été aidé sur le
salarié mais il a fallu s'endetter avec
des prêts garantis par l'État bien
rembourser aujourd'hui
par l'État vous avez mais une
augmentation j'ose même plus dire le mot
augmentation tellement c'est fort quand
on voit des fois cinq et des fois 10
et puis la montée des matières premières
et n'oublions pas que nos professions
sur la grille des salaires a augmenté
les salaires de 16%. alors parlons à
l'instant des boulangers je sais que ça
vous fait à coeur c'est votre rêve
d'enfance de devenir boulanger
d'ailleurs vous avez quatre boulangers à
Paris en plus de vos restaurants
évidemment le gouvernement a compris
l'enjeu politique c'est précieux pour le
pays la boulangerie c'est un lieu de
lien social il y a eu des annonces cette
semaine faites à Bercy on va aller
regarder rapidement un prix plafond à
280 euros le mégawattheure la
possibilité de résilier ou de renégocier
les contrats avec les électriciens le
report d'impôts de charge et un guichet
plateforme qui a été simplifié pour
obtenir de l'État la prise en charge de
40% du surcoût de la facture est-ce que
ces mesures là ce soir lui a Mish que
vous représentez Hôtel Restaurant Les
réclame pour ce secteur là bien
évidemment d'abord on a été entendu on
salue d'ailleurs que pour les TPE on a
été entendu et que ce prix plafond des
280 euros c'est quand même pas les
soldes c'est x 3 de ce qu'on payait
d'habitude
on a entendu les TPE mais il faut
maintenant défendre des PME mais bien
sûr bien sûr il faut continuerait et le
guichet unique simplifié pour que on
puisse faire des déclarations facilement
et on a été entendu aussi par Bercy sur
de demander à nos experts comptables
quand ils ont à rentrer dans ces
systèmes de pas nous facturer voir nos
surfacturer par moment leurs actions
pour nous aider à avoir ces aides mais
on en a absolument besoin aujourd'hui il
y a une TPE tant mieux et on salue
encore l'effort qui a été fait mais les
PME sont en grande souffrance aussi dans
le CHR en même temps vous savez bien que
le quoi qu'il en coûte ne peut pas être
éternel mais vous en avez conscience au
fond c'est pas votre sujet c'est pas
votre problème non non si c'est notre
sujet on ne demande pas à être aidé en
permanence on demande des tarifs
réguliers
là on peut pas considérer aujourd'hui
que vous n'avez pas pu budgéter c'est
cette fois 10 je vous donne un exemple
tout simple je viens de mes confrères
qui m'appellent il me dit écoute la
facture d'octobre c'est 700 euros
2022 la facture de descendre c'est 11000
€. je ne passe pas ce sont mes marges
donc je n'ai plus de marge donc on va
fermer et puis quand vous êtes en
situation de montagne les hôtels
resteront en situation montagne vous
chauffez un peu plus parce que vous
attendez vos clients tout ça ça a un
coût et aujourd'hui ça fragilisé
terriblement toutes ces tous ces
artisans finalement sont des TPE et des
PME mais globalement ce sont des
artisans donc il faut encore un effort
pour l'hôtellerie restauration
aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous réclamer
et puis surtout que l'État pèse tout son
poids dans la négociation avec le
fournisseur d'énergie c'est le système
libéral du marché de l'électricité que
vous critiquez derrière tout ça je
n'osais pas le dire mais
on a eu l'impression d'une spéculation
c'est à quoi ça m'a fait penser c'est
trop jeune pour ça mais à la téléphonie
à une époque tout le monde s'est lancé
dans la téléphonie tout le monde a
spéculé sur la téléphonie et puis
finalement il reste trois acteurs de la
téléphonie aujourd'hui donc on a eu
cette impression qui avait une
spéculation sur l'énergie une
spéculation maladroite et que finalement
et bien finalement c'est encore le
citoyen l'électricité beaucoup moins
haut que de la guerre en Ukraine ça veut
dire que pour vous il faudrait que
l'électricité redevienne ou devienne un
bien public et surtout ça c'est mettre
en péril la compétitivité de nos
entreprises quand on achète de l'énergie
à ce prix là alors il y a les factures
énergétiques qui étranglent les
restaurateurs et les boulangers et puis
il y a la pénurie de main d'oeuvre vous
avez donné ce chiffre 200000 postes dans
l'hôtellerie restauration c'est beaucoup
Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur propose un titre de séjour
pour les 100 papiers dans la
restauration il s'agit du projet de loi
immigration on va l'écouter vous
réagissez juste après
quand j'entends des dirigeants
politiques nous dire que l'on va
régulariser des personnes et que ce
serait la fin de la France je dis que
quand il mange dans des restaurants et
il ne regarde manifestement pas qui leur
fait la plat et c'est plats bien
français parfois sont faits par des
étrangers qui n'ont pas de papiers et
que eux-mêmes quand ils étaient en
responsabilités ont laissé rentrer sur
le président voilà un titre de séjour
pour les métiers en tension c'est-à-dire
la restauration une régularisation en
fait des sans-papiers qui travaillent en
cuisine là il y a urgence vous soutenez
la mesure d'abord il faut pour ces
métiers en tension oui il y a urgence il
faut qu'on nous mette en métier en
tension parce que pour la fin on n'y est
pas encore on pense qu'on va obtenir
cela mais pour l'instant on n'y est pas
encore mais oui parce que ça nous sort
de l'hypocrisie effectivement quand on
passe la tête dans un restaurant et
qu'on regarde un petit peu qui travaille
quand on met la on regarde un petit peu
entre les palissades d'un chantier on
regarde un petit peu et qui travaille
donc à un moment donné il faut sortir de
cette hypocrisie et les Français sont
pas contre ça je ne crois pas la
régulation par le travail certains vous
diront on est à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est l'attractivité du métier qu'il
faut changer pourquoi régulariser des
étrangers si on peut employer des
Français mais non d'abord on a un
problème démographique il faut il va
falloir le regarder en face on a une
société qui change et qui change son
rapport au travail là aussi il va
falloir qu'avec le régalien on regarde
un peu ces nouveaux contrats de travail
et puis on a une ubérisation du travail
qui me paraît bon un peu plus dangereuse
aujourd'hui il y a ces plateformes qui
sont des plateformes qui vous proposent
un emploi parce que vous êtes
auto-entrepreneur et finalement là vous
n'avez quasiment pas de protection
sociale la régularisation ça veut dire
payer des charges aussi pour les
restaurateurs ils sont prêts à ça
aujourd'hui ils sont employés au black
ces personnes étrangères très souvent je
ne défends pas j'appelle ça des
esclavagistes donc je ne défends pas les
gens qui prennent des personnes qui sont
non qui sont en fragilité parce qu'elles
n'ont pas de papier et qu'on les fait
travailler avec des tarifs extrêmement
bas ça c'est scandaleux non non la
régularisation de ce que je cru
comprendre de Gérald de Darmanin c'est
de dire il y a qui sont déjà à l'emploi
qui par moments se retrouvent non plus
de titre de séjour et les lenteurs
administratives ne leur redonne pas un
titre de séjour et aujourd'hui j'ai
énormément de confrères qui m'appellent
en me disant il faudrait m'aider à
renouveler j'ai un apprenti et notamment
pour les apprentis j'ai un apprenti qui
perd son titre de séjour comment on fait
il est en plein milieu en tout cas c'est
l'autre grande bataille qui
se jouait ici à l'Assemblée après la
réforme des retraites je voudrais
terminer cet entretien par
l'alimentation de demain la sobriété
forcée avec la facture énergétique et
l'inflation on sait tous un peu imposés
regarder ce repas de Noël c'est un peu
une image d'Épinal du fromage une pointe
de foie gras et puis la fameuse dinde
tout ça et ben c'est devenu trop cher il
y en avait moins pendant les fêtes
est-ce que il faut le déplorer ou est-ce
que c'est aussi une raison de se réjouir
un changement dans notre alimentation je
pense que c'est une raison de se réjouir
sur nos modes une consommation voire de
nos surconsommations je pense qu'on est
en train de rentrer dans une aire d'une
alimentation plus vertueuse moi je
défends bleu blanc coeur bien sûr parce
que c'est une une marque qui défend un
label qui définit de bons produits
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un bon produit
son impact social combien en
rémunérateur la qualité des sols on
impact environnemental et son impact
nutritionnel et aujourd'hui le combat
amené qui est un combat politique sur
l'alimentation et sur lequel il faut
vraiment travailler c'est sur cette
alimentation à deux vitesses vous avez
une alimentation pour les gens qui vont
bien et qui ont un peu les moyens de
s'offrir ce qu'ils veulent s'offrir et
de comprendre un petit peu ce qu'ils
veulent manger et puis ceux qui n'ont un
pecs qui ont un reste à vivre
extrêmement faible qui ont une
alimentation qui est extrêmement
mauvaise et qui fait qu'ils sont aussi
touchés par des pathologies façon c'est
encore les plus fragiles donc il faut
travailler sur l'île du bon produit
manger mieux manger moins et refaire des
mangeurs des gens qui vont comprendre
manger plus
verts ce serait le bon libre merci merci
je garde ce conseil vous restez avec
nous c'est l'heure d'accueillir les
partis pris de nos affranchis pour
terminer vous allez le voir ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite
Richard Verly du quotidien
Blick quotidien suisse correspondant
parisien les achats Boncelles féministes
engagés et journaliste politique
fondatrice du podcast popopole vos
cartes blanches dans un instant vous
nous parlez de ce qui s'est passé
dimanche à Brasilia vous vous nous
parlez du rapport sur la chasse un plan
sécurité et chasse qui ne vous a pas
convaincu Léa mais d'abord on commence
avec l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée ça
s'appelle Bourbon Express elle va mon
Agava c'est vous qui nous la racontez ce
soir on a un peu parlé déjà à votre très
attendu c'est jouer c'est fini c'est pas
fini non c'est pas fini cette chronique
elle a bien failli pas avoir lieu
normalement j'avais prévu de vous parler
du vote sur les EnR c'est les énergies
renouvelables bon c'était prévu autour
de 18h donc j'avais largement le temps
normalement tout devait se passer comme
prévu sauf que bah c'est souvent le cas
à l'Assemblée surtout en ce moment rien
ne s'est passé comme prévu regardez
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
si alors
attendez s'il vous plaît moi j'ai un
résultat mais effectivement qui doit pas
correspondre au nombre de personnes que
je vois devant moi donc on va on va
relancer le vote
alors son suit finalement et bien des
minutes et des minutes de cafouillage
visiblement il y a un problème technique
certains des conséquences sur notre
plateau exactement considère avec leur
vote n'arrive pas ils arrivent pas à
voter ça marche pas comme il faut donc
la présidence se tourne vers les
huissiers il y a des rappels aux
règlements bref finalement la séance est
suspendue un court instant elle reprend
autour de 18h20 allez tout le monde
croit que ça va aller la Présidente il y
a le brume Pivet elle y croit les
députés ils y croient moi j'y crois et
en fait ma patatra regardez
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclore
alors j'ai un problème en phase
et à gauche
la sincérité du scrutin ne peut pas être
assuré on fait donc on met en place un
vote par bulletin branle-bas de combat
faut imprimer les bulletins les députés
sont convoqués pour voter en fait
ça prend beaucoup de temps on annonce
des résultats autour de 21h30 mais pour
que cette chronique elle est pas
totalement un goût de neige fait je vais
vous le dire normalement ça devrait
passer pour le gouvernement pourquoi le
gouvernement a essayé convaincre la
gauche alors les résultats sont
finalement plus mitigés que prévu les
écologistes devraient s'abstenir ils
l'ont dit bien mon micro tout à l'heure
Charles Fournier le chef de fil des
écologistes
moi naïvement on me dit énergies
renouvelable je pense les écologistes
ils vont voter pour en fait c'est plus
compliqué que ça bah oui bien sûr ça
voudrait dire que finalement parce que
il y a un titre qui s'appelle accès à
les énergies renouvelables les
écologistes sont pour non c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe il faut que le
texte accélère réellement et là
aujourd'hui il accélère pas il freine il
freine pas mais c'est pas un bon texte
alors le salut du gouvernement il vient
des socialistes qui ont décidé de voter
pour le texte même si c'était pas facile
c'est pas facile de faire un cadeau
gouvernement aujourd'hui jour de la
présentation de la réforme des retraites
dont vous avez longuement parlé mais bon
ils ont décidé de distinguer les choses
Dominique Pottier nous explique la
position donc du PS
facile comme position pour un groupe
d'opposition de voter pour un texte du
Gouvernement il n'y a pas de pire
opposition qui est celle qui soit dans
une sorte de posture permanente de dire
non parce que
si un moment donné le ciel est bleu il
faut dire qu'il est bleu s'il est gris
et qu'il y a des gros nuages noirs comme
avec des retraites il faut le dire
également et dénoncer allez normalement
résultat à 21h30 vie normalement parce
que maintenant moi je ne rien jamais on
reste prudent peut-être un faux coulisse
on m'indique quand même que les députés
qui étaient présents et qui ont du filet
pour aller voter ont pu le faire tant
mieux pour eux chacun dans leur camp
politique Richard on enchaîne avec vous
vouliez revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
dimanche à Brasilia cette asso sur les
lieux de pouvoir mais vous vouliez aussi
nous avertir ce soir dans votre carte
blanche attention à ne pas tout
confondre attention ce qui s'est passé
une tentative de putsch au Brésil ne
peut pas se confondre avec la montée des
populistes ou même les radicalités en
Europe oui effectivement est-ce qu'il
faut d'abord c'est rappeler l'effet et
surtout leur similitude avec un certain
6 janvier 20 vous vous souvenez ce qui
s'était passé à Washington avec l'assaut
contre le Congrès des partisans Donald
Trump l'enquête qui a suivi etc et bien
ce dimanche 8 janvier à Brasilia c'est
le même scénario du pire qui a eu lieu
avec des milliers de manifestants
galvanisés par l'ancien président
d'extrême droite jaillir bolsonaro vous
savez qu'il avait refusé de reconnaître
sa défaite et la victoire de l'actuel
président Louna Da Silva et bien ces
milliers de manifestants ont envahi et
saccagé non seulement le Parlement mais
également le palais présidentiel et la
Cour suprême puisqu'on Brésil les trois
se trouvent sur la fameuse place des
trois pouvoirs alors immédiatement on a
entendu pas mal d'éditorialistes dire et
si ça se passait en Europe et on a même
ressorti des images d'archives des
images assez tragiques comme celle de la
manifestation en France du 6 février
1934 il y a 100 ans on s'est rappelé
qu'il y a eu la Marche sur Rome de
Mussolini en Italie on a même évoqué la
marche du nazisme comme si bolsonaro
après Trump d'un seul coup faisait
replonger le vieux continent dans ce
fameux cauchemar de l'entrée de guerre
on parle souvent Emmanuel Macron lorsque
les démocraties chanceler sous la
pression des opinions chauffées à blanc
par les nationalistes
nous dites-vous paniquer ne sert à rien
non même au contraire le pire dans ses
comparaisons avec le Brésil ce serait de
commencer à pointer du doigt tous les
manifestants notamment les gilets jaunes
on y voyant des Pucci ce en quelque
sorte obligatoire n'oublions pas qu'à
Brasilia comme à Washington les foules
se sont mobilisées parce que des leaders
les ont manipulés et ce sont des leaders
qui ont refusé le résultat des urnes
c'est à cela qu'il faut veiller le
danger ne vient pas de la rue mais de
ceux qui l'exploitent et qui
transforment les manifestations et la
colère sociale on arme anti-démocratique
je l'ai dit Trump et bolsonaro avait
refusé de reconnaître leurs défaites
alors je ne dis pas que les démocraties
européennes sont immunisées mais pour
l'instant nous n'en sommes encore pas là
y compris dans des pays qu'on pointe du
doigt pour leur dérive autoritaire comme
la Pologne ou la Hongrie n'oublions pas
aussi que l'Union européenne sert de
rempart à leur soyons vigilants mais ne
paniquons pas surtout ne jetons pas la
faute sur le peuple mais regardons ce
qu'il est manipule ce sont eux les
premiers coupables une réaction à cette
édito cette carte blanche de Richard
et ses leaders des fois autoproclamés
qui chauffables évidemment la foule qui
la manipule comme ça vient d'être dit et
qui sont en Europe mais attention quand
on voit quand même non mais on est quand
même aujourd'hui à entendre à contester
une élection incontesté il y a quand
même cette ce relent du petit complot
permanent oui bien sûr bien sûr parce
que à un moment donné le cadre le cadre
d'une république et fragile et il faut
il faut maintenir ce cadre et c'est
compliqué on l'a vu pendant notre crise
des gilets jaunes c'était extrêmement
intéressant d'ailleurs on sait tous on
était très choqués par ces gilets jaunes
parce qu'on se disait mais ça aurait pu
être moi
j'aurais pu être là sur les trois
premières législations après on voit la
dérive et puis les manipulations mais là
je vous rejoins le peuple a dit non stop
on n'a pas besoin de leader alors on va
enregistrer un sujet qui je pense va
vous intéresser la chasse Léa vous
vouliez pousser un coup de gueule contre
le plancha c'est sécurité qui a été
présenté hier par la secrétaire d'État
l'écologie oui alors en effet je voulais
pousser un coup de gueule parce qu'à mon
son ce n'est pas tout à fait
satisfaisant et j'ai parfois le
sentiment que le gouvernement a une
oreille davantage attentive quand il
s'agit des chasseurs que des promeneurs
car comme vous le savez l'interdiction
la chasse de dimanche n'a pas été
retenue dans ce projet pourtant les
accidents ont majoritairement lieu le
week-end et les dimanches par ailleurs
78% des Françaises des Français se
disent favorables à cette mesure donc on
est un peu étonné il y a quand même une
petite victoire arrachée ou pas avec ce
plan alors effectivement rassurez-vous
il ne sera plus possible de chasser
quand on abus de l'alcool ni quand on a
consommé des drogues c'est quand même
intéressant de constater qu'il a fallu
attendre 2023 pour qu'il mesure telle
que celle-ci soit sur la table je dis
enfin parce qu'on sait tous et tout
autour de la table que alcool et chats
ne font pas toujours bon ménage et
pourtant vous nous dites que c'est pas
tout à fait gagner sur ce sujet pourquoi
alors non ce n'est pas tout à fait
gagner parce que pour le moment il
s'agit d'une simple contravention pour
venir sanctionner le fait de consommer
de l'alcool de manière excessive par
ailleurs lors des lors de la chasse
ensuite ce texte devrait être
effectivement inscrit dans la loi pour
devenir un délit donc le gouvernement va
devoir présenter un texte afin qu'il
soit voté par les parlementaires or on
le sait le lobby des chasseurs en France
est particulièrement influent
souvenez-vous lorsque le Sénat avec
préconisé d'interdire tout simplement
l'alcool pendant la chasse les chasseurs
étaient montés au créneau le président
de la Fédération des Chasseurs de France
a même dit que c'était absolument
stigmatisant que c'était brutal comme
mesure moi je me dis que c'est quand
même un point de vue étant donné qu'on
sait qu'il y a quand même 9% des
accidents mortels qui sont dus à la
consommation excessive d'alcool et donc
Willy Shrek on sent souvent s'en
souvient avait eu gain de cause
qu'est-ce qui va se passer maintenant
alors
alors maintenant ce qui va se passer
c'est que effectivement que je vous le
disais ce texte va devoir être adopté ou
non par les parlementaires à suivre moi
j'ai envie de vous dire j'espère
vraiment que le gouvernement n'a pas
épuisé toutes ces cartouches si vous
m'autorisez cette expression tout de
même c'est-à-dire en fait on le sait
l'alcool effectivement
altère en fait les capacités de
réflexion altèrent aussi même le
jugement altère la vision l'audition les
réflexes donc on peut se dire quand même
on pourrait mettre en place une mesure
préventive de sorte d'affaires en sorte
que l'alcool soit parfaitement interdit
lorsqu'on est en train de chasser on
pourrait par ailleurs et c'est réfléchir
aussi à des mesures qui soient un peu
plus dissuasives comme c'est déjà le cas
dans d'autres pays comme en Suisse
notamment qui qui vient en fait
sanctionner le fait d'avoir consommé de
l'alcool par un retrait du permis tout
simplement donc on est pas du tout assez
répressif en la matière à mon sens vous
souriez oui parce qu'il y a un humoriste
français walidia qui disait c'est
étonnant ils mettent une tenue camouflée
et un gilet fluorescent
[Musique]
là on est à quoi plus de 80% des
Français qui se sont 78%
voilà franchement on m'a toujours pas
réussi à le faire comment le comprendre
c'est le fameux ça veut dire que ce
serait l'interdiction plus simple de la
chasse si on peut plus chasser les je
mange il y aura plus de
pratique le week-end et c'est ou alors
ça serait que pour des gens qui vivent
en milieu rural donc ça me paraît
compliqué mais il y a un regard sur mais
je pense qu'il faut laisser aussi les
choses s'atténuer on voit bien que la
chasse c'est plus un réflexe permanent
en milieu rural on voit on voit bien que
des gens se désintéressent aussi cette
activité
de nuisance en la matière montrer
l'exemple je suis pas sûr que les
Suisses montrent l'exemple on a les
mêmes problèmes la différence c'est que
pour une bonne partie l'achat s'est
exercée en montagne et le j'allais dire
le trafic piéton en montagne et moins
important qu'il ne peut l'être autour de
village français par contre en revanche
je confirme que sur la question de
permis de conduire la législation en
Suisse est très très rude pour prendre
un exemple que je connais parce que un
ami à moi vient de l'expérimenter dans
le canton de vous On vous retire le
permis c'est-à-dire Lausanne On vous
retire le permis immédiatement ça
s'appelle et vous devez payer le
rapatriement de votre voiture merci
beaucoup merci les affranchis merci Elsa
pour cette première et merci
d'être venu un grand parrain je le
disais j'espère qu'il va nous porter
chance pour cette nouvelle année Thierry
Marx à votre place demain c'est Darius
Rochebin le journaliste qui sera là pour
nous parler de son prochain livre son
dernier livre pardon sur sur Gorbatchev
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire bien sûr
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain même
le même
[Musique]